For this next problem, we're going to be once again working with a nice constant electric field
and let's imagine that we put two charges in this field, one positive charge and one negative charge,
and we align these two charges such that if you draw a line between the two of them,
this line is perpendicular to the field lines.
We know that there are two forces acting on each of these particles.
There is the electrostatic force trying to pull them together and there is the force from the electric field
which for this negative charge is going to be pushing it down this way
and for this positive charge is going to be pushing it upwards this way.
Let's say that we once find the net force acting on this positive charge,
it makes this angle θ₁ with the horizontal here
and when we find the net force acting on this negative charge particle,
it turns out to make this nice angle θ₂ with the horizontal.
Given only these two angles,
can you tell me what the ratio between these two charges has to be?
What is the charge of the positively charged particle
divided by the charge of the negatively charged particle?
Put your answer here.